foreign
hypercube to the end
um
looks almost like this it's really sorry
I hear myself it's really hard
kind of look like this at least for n
equals three and
you can try to imagine how it looks for
louder ends but
I don't know exactly
um
and we have the the
graphs or every coordinate here is
actually associated with the element in
the group z to the to the n
and the function is on the vertices to
associate uh value for every vertex
and
it's good to know these graphs or we
have Edge between two uh
note the difference in exactly one
coordinate
and Boolean function does give two
values so you can think about zero one
two colors minus one one
[Music]
so I like to think about it like to
coloring of the graph and then we can
see that we have two
uh different uh kind of headers there
are the inferential adjust the
multi-chromatic letters
and uh
just with the same color
so the the bipromatic I just called the
intervention because they influence the
value of the function
and now we can Define the influence of a
bit of one variable or you can look on
all the edges in the direction I and see
how many edges are influential and this
many edges up to some normalization is
exactly the influence of the variable I
and the total interest defined to be the
summation of all of them which is
exactly the number of influential edges
in the entire Cube
up to the same normalization
um
these Notions are important to know
and
Let's do let's see how we do this um
in for your representation
okay
okay so one important function that we
want to introduce is the derivative
function this is the partial derivative
function so for every direction I we can
see how much the function uh changed
when we go in this direction
so this is defined to be the function
the value of f on x
minus the value of x i for x i is
filter
is exactly the same as X
where the B the height bit is flipped
this will be minus x i
x i minus 1.
so the function
FX is function on minus one one two n to
minus 1 1.
um you know
um okay so I'll change plus minus one
zero one
whenever I want so I hope it will not be
confused with this
and
so if if
is Boolean
that it's go to plus minus one
then the values that we get here is
either minus one plus one or zero
so we can see that we get plus plus one
when
I
is influential here
and zero otherwise
okay
so now if we think about the definition
of the influence
foreign
this will be exactly
the probability when
EX
it's not the same as f
x with I flipped with I bit flipped
and become exactly the probability that
the derivative function
the partial derivative is not zero
so now we can write it as the
expectation
um so whenever it's not zero it's
exactly
when it is plus or minus one
so we can take the square of it
excuse me
thank you
um
yeah okay so now we have the expectation
of some functions class or it's very
interesting to see how is this function
as for yeah
how it's Fourier expansion looks like
because now we can use Percival
to have
um maybe something interesting
what is this quantity so it's very easy
to calculate it
um so let us do it uh here
X
the Rope
um
basic words to We can take the expansion
here and here and we can see that just
become a summation of all the characters
that as I
thank you
okay so this makes sense because in the
right direction all the characters that
doesn't contain I just
do nothing
um
and
okay
some interesting fact
about four-year presentation of school
and functions
so if
is Boolean
then what we know about
the Fourier coefficient Square
what do we know about this imagine it's
equals one right
so now we have a summation of
non-negative
numbers that sum up to one we can think
about it as distribution
so we can think about uh let's call it
the Fourier distribution
which just pick every character
or just subset of and as we talked there
we talk to the fan
with probability the Fourier coefficient
Square
okay so now what is the influence of the
ice variable
just exactly the probability that
s contains I
foreign
now if we think about the total
influence
which does the summation of all the
influences we want to write it as a
four-year representation
or you can sum all the characters that
contains I
this just become we count now every
character as its size exactly
sorry to become
[Music]
the size of this
so now this is exactly the
expected size
Factor s
and this will be useful sometimes
it becomes to be the expected degree of
the function
so the degree of the function I guess
that mentioned here it's just the
largest Fourier coefficient that not
zero
very
[Music]
um
now one thing so everything that we did
up to now was for Boolean functions with
values plus minus one but we can now
take
um the influence to be defined
just as this
it's for your presentation and can work
for every function
that goes to our
and also the total influence just the
same remain the same definition
and this will be useful sometimes when
we want to do about with contents that
are not exactly Boolean
um
I think even about the functions after
you applied some noise
um
let me introduce the
first I guess
so you can think about the definition as
just the summation of
uh the influences
I think this makes more sense yeah just
think about it like this but on the um
you're defining now the influence for a
general real-time function okay so for
the individual influence you can think
about the definition as the probability
that f x is not equal to f x when we
when you flip the bit I for Boolean
functions
and then you can think about the
generalized definition as just the
Fourier presentation and when you sum
all of them so for the total influence
it's become the same
just some of them
okay let me introduce the KKL theorem
one of the questions that uh yeah
distribution
so it's not necessarily the situation
but you always can normalize the
function with the summation of all the
Fourier coefficients
um
you have to get the summation is one
sorry about it
[Music]
okay so it started with the rock with
the north linear
um
on Collective coin flipping and they
found uh they thought what happened when
the throttle instrument is small
how the our small can be the individual
inferences and they found the tracks
function
which has
um
the fan Chan
it's off and or in the force
or you just
say or
the old function of
and
of
many bits so we have many ants
and
um
so this function has every uh for some
power methods of how many hours you have
here and how many ants and every
individual bit has influenced
along the end
the total influence is
the function is actually hyper
okay so balance start
[Music]
okay so this function is interesting why
because it has some total implants and
all the influences are not very small
and they ask the question whether you
can have
okay so what's a trivial instance that
we have whenever we have some total
inference it's always the fact that and
go up there exists some Iris the
individual influence is this is like
very trivial right
what's an inference at least n just
because it's summation
um
if you have for example total insurance
slogan
and then
you have
[Music]
individual influence at least again over
n and the question that asks whether
it's possible to have some total
implants and
all the inference very small like to
have a smaller thought of influence
and all the let's say that the focal
inference will be a little or of n
the question
or vlogging sorry
is it possible that all
I influence I of f
is about
the total influence over end that are
all small together
um
and they try to use combinatorial
tools to find some function like this
and they didn't find and then they came
Khan kalai and lineal KKL
and they were the first to use the
Fourier
analysis to solve Boolean functions
questions
and
they showed that
this is actually not possible
the answer is no
and every function
every balanced movement function at
least but also an untrivial result for
non-balance
as at least one individual instance
which is
large
example
let f
in Boolean function
let's say it's balanced balance they
interested
uh the expectation of f
zero I think it's that minus one one in
simple ability
then
this term I will implement
I is at least
some constant times login
over n
and what will this we'll do today we
will prove this third one so it has some
proofs and some of them are very easy
and chopped we'll do today the longest
one
but it's very interesting and here's
some interesting techniques
um just before we go to the techniques
let's talk about another version of KKL
ore
there's always exists some high reason
influence I
think is at least
two to minus the total influence
we put here some constants or not
from constant
so what they actually proved is this
version so let us see for a minute
how we can imply
the first from the second because
it's very easy
one place two
employees first
or if the total influence is large
It's a larger than
Logan ever
see
then it's trivial right
just divide by n Andrea
and otherwise
you can see that using two
at least
two
is one over square root and much larger
than what we need
Okay so
we will prove all of this together never
mind we'll prove the first one but just
we need this this way
um
during the another interesting
it's called freedom but
I'm not talking about it now
um
and
a little bit
okay so the the first proofs for kkln 3
driven from the theorems
um there there were the first to use the
for your analysis and hyperconductivity
um things like that and
why I don't think
never mind
I know there are another proofs
um that use uh either paramedic
qualities and stochastic calculus
and
oh okay
I want to show it also okay maybe I'm
not that time
never mind
um
okay uh
[Music]
yeah and they didn't get any instruction
for this so you can definitely do okay
um
okay so the main tool that we are going
to see today and we'll we'll want to do
everything about restrictions but almost
everything so we know how to do it
exactly and as restrictions so Hamlet
mentioned that to deal with the higher
degrees we can use
um noise operator that just kills them
somehow so we'll find another way to
kill
thousand degrees
there are large characters
so let's assume that we have some
function
with many variables and we just choose a
subset of them
colorful ones
to be the live variables
and the other ones
we are going to set to assign some
values we are going to fix them is the
way that we kill them minus one one
[Music]
um
and then we end up with a function that
we are going to denote it fjz where J is
a set of Allied variables and this is
the fixing of the other variables this
is one from
-1 1 to J in that
this means to our and the values of the
function defines to be the same values
as the original function
um with the fixing Z so somehow this
this just go through some sub cube of
the function and takes the values there
foreign
so let's see how it looks in
your presentation did you say that there
there are proofs that don't use cyber
contractivity
okay
what kind of they use log sober of
inequality which is kind of insane but
[Music]
yes I miss herd also is this
is
what was the question is there a proof
with like you said you said there was a
slide that you skipped when you said
there's
people yeah so there is a proof of
okay yeah there is yeah
he's going to talk about it I guess
it's important in this uh what what so
what is the news what is the proof for
diaper with isometric inequality
foreign
let's have our function
s
also for some general functions and
Okay so
let's see what is the Fourier
presentation of f
go over all the characters with
associated with subset of n the Fourier
coefficient
now we have our J
and the restriction
and let's see how the Fourier
coefficients of the restricted function
how that looks like so
what is the value of this function we
can use the Fourier expansion of f
so this is exactly
the Fourier coefficients of s the
character s of
z and y
we can separate the character as
on the values of z and y okay if it's
not okay some ones are just let me know
so we can Z as outside J
and Y is inside J
and now Z is fixed
so this thing becomes constant
and the character here is now associated
with s intersection with j
and we have many of them in this
summation so let's group all of them
together
what are the characters that we're going
to have here are there are all the
subset of the of J
um
very expension over s
s and J
okay
why
do what we have here
so this quantity becomes the Fourier
coefficient
foreign
presentation of
the restricted function
and reduce this
foreign
I think that I said that we are going to
talk about random restrictions and now
we talked about restrictions not random
so let's randomize them a bit
um
so we can choose Z randomly so let's say
that we fix J
and now we just we don't just take
specific zero we randomize it over all
the options here
so now we get that the function
f
j z is a random function
and we can ask questions about how it
looks like in expectation for example
so what is
the expectation of
let's say what is expectation of the sum
Fourier coefficient
together
or you can see that
all the Fourier coefficient that
of F that contribute
to the Fourier coefficient T in the
restriction
um there are those that have
some intersection with Jain which is
exactly t
and they contribute to risk different
signs and their sign Define
by the character
that left
in s and not in G with z
so they sometimes will be plus and
sometimes minus
and they will cancel in expectations
they will cancel each other except to
one
and the one that will not cancel will be
the one that s is exactly k for then
here we have S minus J is the principal
character and
the sign doesn't change
this is not useful fact I think I don't
know why why you should use it but the
only the thing that I want to see here
is that
actually the Fourier coefficient as
represented here as a function of Z with
the Fourier representation of this
function so
if we Define let's say GT of Z
to be the
magnet
the Fourier coefficient
in the restriction
we have this expansion so this is all
the s
it has
the section exactly here
you just copy it from here
and the expectation of the function as
we already know is just the
principle Fourier coefficient and
if we want to know what is the
expectation of the Fourier coefficient
Square
now we have easy formula first of all
right so this is exactly the summation
of all the Fourier coefficients that has
intersection with J exactly
foreign
new
quantity of Boolean functions
let us talk about the
level K weights
so the rate K of the function f
just Define it to be
the weight of the characters of size
okay
think about it as the probability of s
equals
okay
an s
chosen from the Fourier distribution
now we can ask what is the
level K weight expectedly for the
restrictions of facts
oh sorry uh F sub uh that's the that's
uh you put you put Z on the coordinates
index by S
Rod FS comments
what is it
yeah
he's in J complement yeah yeah
and you wrote you wrote I guess you
wrote the magnitude of s intersect right
that's just without that so but that's
about the time the magnitude
it's a couple of times
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much for this
oh yeah you're acceptable it's like the
size
okay thank you for listening
okay let's see what the level K rate of
the restricted function
expectation over Z
this is just calculations
information over on PSI
by definition
now we can take
you already
know what else the expected character
coefficient Square
so we can click it here
these are just as I mentioned
yes
okay now with the size of this set it
was great
um
10 questions
it's okay
so
let's do more on the mediation
thank you
so what's left to
to do random
so we can randomize J
um
so let's see about
so let's choose every J to be in j
esus
enjoying with probability meal
we can stay alive
um
before we do this
two important facts fun fact and one
example
so if the function is Boolean every
restriction of this will be in Boolean
okay
um just pull it takes a sub tube and one
example that makes sense I think
um
so let's think about the address
function so what is the address function
we've took a K plus K variables
between about zero one now just to
confuse it
we have two 2K variables
then we have another K variables
and how the function choose its values
so it looks what values we have here
and
it takes the
the address from here and choose some
variable
and now it will be the value of this
so this is the address function
and come as example for many things and
if you think about restriction let's say
that we take J to be the
the first two to claim any variables and
then we fix some address
then we end up with function that's
called how
this is just a dictatorship okay so
every we can see that every restriction
that
remember okay so what is the type of
shape
this is just a function that
uh
when ethics just equals x i this is just
exactly what you think it is you have
one variable that defines a function
Define the value of the function
ignition
okay example
f x equals x i for some for some I or it
might be sometimes we talk about the
negative declaratorship with minus x x i
so sometimes they come together
[Music]
um
we'll talk more about these
dictatorships
okay
but
it's for this let's go to random day
unless you have any questions about this
um okay so what that what happened when
we choose J randomly
or from this process we get
FJ
we do two steps steps step one is to
find Jack to choose J
and then step two
we take random
Z
from the rest of the variables
now we end up with a function
which is randomized by j and z
minus one one okay
so now even the domain of J is the size
of it is randomized so for example how
many
variables are going to stay alive
for every variable independently is
going to be responsibility and you stay
alive so we expect to have mu n
and
for every character
we expect
exactly the same fraction
so for every s
the expectation of s intersection with j
is going to be mu times s and why is
this interesting
for the contribution of the Fourier
coefficient of s
is going to contribute exactly the
weight
um
and the characters that has some small
interception
we are here in the characters that has
after the the random restriction the
contribution to some level will be
exactly the in size of the intersection
of s and J
so you can see now that this is a way to
take large Fourier coefficients
and
when we do one demonstration
we push their rate to low levels
or let's say for example of a function
f
B homogeneous
vet function
of the greedy
homogeneous function of degree D is
function that has only
non-zero for your coefficients only on
characters of that of size d another way
to say it is that
uh
respect
room of f
think about Epsilon equals zero here
um
just contain only
is or S equals
[Music]
so if we think about such a function and
we want to take all the the weight the
level on the level the weight to very
low degrees
it will be useful to use mu to be 1 over
d
so if mu equals one over D for example
then for every s yeah
expect
[Music]
um
and J
it's actually one
and more than that the probability that
s and J the intersection of s and J
equals one
population one minus one over ND to D
minus one
approximately one I see I mean some
constant
perform zero
um
now
let's see what is up here
foreign
actually care about the level one
first exit functions
for jmz
also weight is going to go to the level
one at least a huge fraction of it 2.2
about 11 1 with high probability sorry
I'm going to have here
uh which are of one
or these specific functions
and we can relax a little bit the
requirement of f to be
exactly homogeneous of DVD
let's think of have such that the
room of
characters of size
uh approximately
let's say that there are at least 2D
um
also here you still have the the
probability is very large
and now again
the Fourier coefficient
we're going to contribute to the level
one
and we can even let the function to have
some rate outside of these levels
and if we have just at least constant
rate on the levels between D half and 2D
then when we restrict the function and
look at the level one
we'll have at least constant
wait there
and we are going to use this kind of
functions and they're just say why it is
sometimes useful to think about
functions like this why it makes sense
to think about them
oh if you think about all the characters
their sizes or ranges between 0 and then
we can take them
it's called The Attic partition
we can partition all the characters to
according to the to the size let's say
take all the characters
such that s is in between n and n half
and then another this will be us
rotation okay let me not not denote this
and the other
partition would be
more than that in between and half and
and first
and so on so how many uh parts we are
going to end up we have only log n
so we know that at least one of these
partitions is going to have one over
login weight
which is not very small so
uh instead of run over Logan we'll think
about that we will have constant but we
can deal also with one overall again
and I think that we are ready to prove
KKL for some
assumptions
so let's assume that our function is of
degree d
which means that
uh
the weight on the characters between DF
and 2D is at least constant
so now if we want to push the
the way to level one it makes sense to
take mu equals one over d
uh and then we get that the expectation
of the first Fourier level is constant
so now we know that there exists at
least one J
from all the options today that such
that the weight is this constant so let
us fix this specific day
and
so now we have the text location over
this this constant let us do strong
assumptions but not too strong maybe and
assume that for everything it's exactly
one
um so now what we
can all from this
so I'll just remind you that f j z the
restricted function is Boolean because
we started with Boolean function
and when we have a Boolean function that
has all of its rate one actually this is
all of its rate on the first Fourier
level it's actually quite easy to see
that it must be a dictatorship
um
you have to convince you or your
convinced
okay
so let's do it a little bit
um
so what does it mean that the function
has all of its for four Fourier
coefficients on all of its four era from
the degree one
means that it looks something like this
so our f of x
and i f i
now think about that you have two
a different two let's do it enough that
are not zero at least two
so let's say without loss of generality
that's the first one and the second one
are not zero
and so it equals to summation
all right
F1
plus F2
plus something
nutrients are on
foreign
let's fix all the variables from 3 to n
so where we are some fixed value call it
C
and
let's take the four four different
values of f
so we can put an X1 and X2 plus 1 minus
1 and
I can take or start to do it and
hopefully I can
stop in the middle
so one of the values
will be the first one plus the second
one plus C and the second
will be
you can put here minus F2
let's see and we have another two values
here
and we are going to end up with three
different values
this three I think even for different
values of the function but we have only
two values of the functions
we have only one
uh
at most one for your coefficient that is
that is not zero and if it's not zero it
must be one and if it's one must be that
FX equals to x i
either x i o minus x i because the four
equation might be minus one
okay so now your convince is this that
um so we can think about all the
restrictions as
uh if we let this assumption to be so
all the restrictions are dictatorships
so for every for every Z
we have some J some x j
small J
that is the dictatorship associated with
fjz
coming back to our Boolean here
um
so we have this Association and we can
do a partition of all disease according
to what J is apic to be there
um
so we have some group that have
x j and x k and XL
and
now we want to know what is the size of
this uh
of these warps how large AJ is
and so
I'm going to claim that this is exactly
the influence
and so let's see why why it is true so
you can see that for everything in AJ
XJ must be in fragile because when you
put Z then XJ Define the
when you fix Z XJ Define the function
and
change the function if we change it
and for every other
group Al for example x j must be not
influential because here
XL is the inferential variable and we
have dictatorships or we have only one
influential variable
so this is exactly the influence and
what we wanted to to prove
want to prove that the influence is at
least will be an over n
so if so if we have some influence which
is large then we are done we have the
KKL so let us assume that all of them
are small okay this is not
both of them but
so if we assume that all of them are
small
then we have something to pull
and
of course we have to prove so if you
remember how we we derived the first
version from the second
we showed that if the influence is small
then it must be at least one individual
inference which is large so now we'll do
the opposite if the influencers are all
small then we are going to show that the
total influence is large
so how can we show that the total
influence is large we have to find the
influential edges in the cube where
where they hide here so we talked about
the edges inside the
um the partition in inside the the
subsets ajs ajal
Korean we left now with the edges in
between
and
so we can see that every Edge in between
is influential
why it's influential because it's one
from X J the dictatorship XJ through
dictatorship XL
so actually it's not older just half of
them are going to be influential
whenever XJ and Excel have different
value
it's hard to work to see it
um so let us count how many edges we
have in between
actually we have edges of parametric
inequality let's say that
if the
if we have a set of a small set very few
uh
that's in the Boolean Cube then we have
many are just going outside of it
okay
so you should think about it they are
going from one dictatorship to another
differential
so whenever these two variables the
title shape are different it's going to
be influential
it's possible for this to be like a
range
is there some reason that you expect
half of the edges to be
foreign
set
um so you can see that
this is The Edge boundary
uh it depends on the size of the
um actually recycle the density of
the the sets or as the density is
smaller we have more edges
around the outside
I'm not convinced you now about this but
we can do it in the next hour
just if we sum up now all the just in
between
so we we actually some
if you remember we thought that the
density of this groups is small it's
almost one over score then so it means
that we have at least the number of of
nodes in each group Times login they're
just going outside some of them together
yet
many sensitive edges between slogan
we do the normalization of the inference
and we get that the total inference is
at least log n which is exactly what we
wanted to say
okay if it's at least login then we have
trivially larger implants
um so we proved the kikele
which is a long Direction and not for
all the cases but
a topic was interesting
um
so I guess I will take questions offline
or in the next hour or whatever